okay um so uh good I well good afternoon
everybody um my name is John hean I go
by a bunch of bunch of different names
PhD Bor historicus I do a lot of yelling
on Twitter I uh I'm still currently a
student unfortunately um working through
that with the pandemic kind of threw
everything off a little bit um but this
is my first time I guess coming back and
being able to speak um in person um
rather than just online which is you
know pretty fantastic um and so uh what
I'm going to kind of talk to you about
today um is going to be not necessarily
a topic that's immediately going that's
going to be immediately practical to
your software engineering Endeavors but
sort of talking about um the direction
of a programing language that you know a
lot of us in this room use daily um or
at least did use daily or have to
interrupt with daily or struggle with
daily um and it's C right
um and I want to talk about the idea of
C coming back right um so it wasn't
necessarily dead because it was kind of
everywhere but people had sort of
consigned to the idea that like oh it's
not going to see updates anytime soon
and if there are updates they're not
going to be very significant and no
one's going to really do anything with
it and so on and so forth um and that
could not have been further from the
truth um there was an explosive number
of additions in the latest release that
is going to be uh c23 which
is in tradition of c89 C excuse me C90
um c99 being published a year later
C7 not being published in 20 2018 um c23
is going to be published in 2024 um so
uh you know it's just scheduling and you
have to get ISO to agree to stuff and
you do balloting and do National body
comments the iso process is very
heavy
uh yes the standard has an off by one
error which you know that's that's that
that's why you you know it plagues you
because we we didn't get it right when
we keep keep publishing the standard
right but the one time we do get it
right all the one by off by one errors
will disappear um I hope I'm hoping
that's like a cursing because if it's
not then we're all just you know we're
in trouble but um but yeah so
specifically I want to talk about C
coming back into the Zeitgeist I guess
um and more importantly I want to talk
about this idea of
Unbreaking this
Charter
right and so what do I what do I mean by
Charter right so generally a charter for
any organization is like your goals your
mission what am I going to do what are
we going to do out in the world what are
we you know how are we going to help
people or maybe not help people if
that's what your mission is I hope
that's not your mission but you know you
can say whatever you want in your
Charter and that's supposed to Define
your organization your goals your
mission right and so as a standards body
um you don't actually have to have a
charter but we do have one for c um in
particular we have one for every
revision major revision of C we usually
put out a charter that
defines what it is we're doing right um
You can see the 1994 one is a little bit
too old um so we don't actually have
like a a link to that one um but we got
one next year right from talking about
c9x Charter right so this is one we
talking about c99 right so we're past
the c89 threshold we're coming up on
like 10 years old or getting closer to
the 10-y old thresh Mark which is about
every time we release a standard right
once every 10 years basically um and
so we have a c9x charter we have a c1x
charter for C11 um and then we have a
preliminary c2x Charter and then we
eventually got to an actual c23 Charter
um with you know like scheduling and
other stuff right um and the authors of
all these papers are conveners the
people who were leading the committee so
I think at some point Robert you might
actually have to be responsible for
writing the charter um and telling us
what we're going to be doing with our
lives for the next uh I don't know I
think you said you were you were
committed for 3 years at least minim my
plan six years okay so six years you
heard it here first six years
um but the idea behind this document is
that it tells us what exactly the
committee wants to do and what exactly
the standard is supposed to be for right
who's it supposed to serve um who
supposed to be helping who we supposed I
mean I wouldn't say hurting but you know
maybe who we're not supposed to be
prioritizing right things we're supposed
to be focusing on that sort of thing
right and so kind of as we did this um
there's some particularly notable
principles or things that kind of pop
out from this uh uh document right um
now all of these have like c89 and c99
and C11 and whatever listed on them but
what's important to not is that all of
these principles actually still remain
the same same more or less throughout
the entire duration of the standard
right each time there was a charter all
we really did was add additional
principles we didn't really remove any
or uh change too many except for like in
one specific case where we should where
I'm going to talk about that a little
bit um but in c89 it was about existing
code right like there was a bunch of
code written by on on k&r from the 70s
and 80s and they had to make sure that
that stuff kept working um and so a lot
of that Focus was on existing code
existing you know make sure that the
code work but they kind of said yeah we
can throw your implementation in the
garbage right if you write an
implementation and you know we make some
changes and you you know you know your
compiler Falls over well that's your
problem right um in practice that's not
actually what happened we actually bend
over backwards to accommodate compilers
and and implementers and being able to
implement things in the worst way
possible um we uh we love letting we
love we love this the term called
quality of implementation where you know
we say you can have a really good
implementation and then we kind of leave
off the fact that you can also have
really bad one um but what we said is
that existing code is very important and
the idea is that the standard is this
kind of treaty between you know you and
your vendor right your implementer the
person who's giving you your compiler
and maybe your standard library and any
other utilities that come along with
it um c99 we were trying to focus on
Simplicity
which not sure we hit that Mark but we
definitely tried um but that was the
focus for c99 it was like maintain
conceptual Simplicity kind of focus on
that C11 was more about trusting the
programmer but then we kind of realized
around C1 time it's like oh we've got a
lot of you know like hacking became real
like in like the 21st century like it
started actually hitting a lot of people
a lot of targets um it started blowing
up a little bit and so for C11 it was
like yeah we should trust the programmer
like you know as like a a thing that's
like a general purpose thing but you
know when it comes to security we should
probably maybe tone it down a little bit
you know you
know wind it back some um and and go
about that way right and then finally in
c23 we added one just one principle and
that was that um apis that we write
should be kind of self-documenting right
so if you can have if you can use a uh
an attribute or something else to
describe what is going on in the
function whether or not it uh modifies
Global State um or if what the size of
the array is where possible um you
should use that kind of markup right
that is available in the standard that
almost nobody knows about right um
question who here knows about stat array
extents that you can use on
parameters one of you and you're on the
committee
so yeah it's
it's yeah it's it's it's it's uh it's C
exclusive it's not supported by C++
which is why it's usually thrown out
because you have a header file you try
to use stack extens to document your API
um and then you have to throw it out
when you compile with C++ or you get a
bug report because somebody's like I
compiled this with my GCC g++ whatever
and it broke and it's like I what is
this and it's like oh it doesn't matter
and you just throw it out and then you
go back to using raw
pointers ah um okay but we tried to say
that where possible you know API should
be self-documenting they should describe
themselves right so if you have a size
you can you know add the array extension
the parameter and put static in there
and then put the actual like parameter
name and that would like describe like
this is an array of at least size n and
stuff like that right um and so we
wanted to make sure that this was
self-documenting where
possible
yeah it's also not I
mean Microsoft is a c89 compiler with
extensions and that's kind of fa to
treat it um unfortunately uh but they
are making leaps and strides and
improving their support for Stuff um so
they might not get static extents um I
they probably figure it's just like not
worth supporting um and I mean they
wouldn't be too terribly wrong because
most people don't use it um but uh they
are making improvements um but we'll
talk about Microsoft and the things they
did in particular um and their effect on
the
ecosystem um specifically one of the
things that's in this giant Charter
document is this idea of keep the spirit
of sea right so you know you have all
these things right a trust the
programmer B don't prevent the the
programmer from doing what needs to be
done C keep the language small and
simple which constantly gets thrown at
me um provide only one way to do an
operation Robert mentioned this in his
in his keynote earlier today um e is you
have to make it fast even if it's
guaranteed to not be portable right um
and F is something we added and we kind
of kind of we kind of
shoveled in there you know at C C11 time
when you know the world was on fire and
we were getting a lot of CVS and stuff
um we said make support for Safety and
Security demonstrable right and that was
kind of temper a right you know we had
to like you know yeah trust the
programmer but not all the time right
you know it's a trade-off you know that
sort of thing
um did we do that right did we actually
like achieve that goal in standardizing
any of the versions of C that we've been
standardizing so far right so all the
way from c99 to c23 have we been doing
that have we been following our Charter
right um and it really depends on who
you ask right um some people think that
c23 is going to you know set the world
on fire and Destroy Everything other
people think you know uh you know we've
we've wrecked the the process and we're
doing everything backwards and
inappropriate and that's why we keep
making worse and worse standards that's
a from from their perspective um and
other people think it's like it has some
really good improvements in there that
they want right um it really does depend
on who you talk to right but you know um
we're going to kind of go through some
very specific pieces of criticism from
both inside and outside the committee so
this was a paper from someone inside the
committee Martin seore very longtime C
member I think he dates all the way back
to um I like how I'm dating committee
members he dates all the way back to uh
uh mid late 990s um been on the
committee for a while been helping
people been implementing stuff at GCC
and in other places for a long time um
and so he kind of wrote this paper
during like the end like 2020 like like
you know like yeah 2022 um about how
we've been standardizing stuff for c23
in particular right and basically you
know his contention was that we were
kind of violating the charter right a
lot of what the charter said is that
we're not supposed to be um that we're
supposed to be codifying existing
practice that we're supposed to be
taking things from things that exist in
implementations right that we're not
supposed to be inventing things right
and especially in C11 and later on we
really double down on that when we put a
clause no invention no exceptions right
like no exceptions to like not like no
exceptions like C++ exceptions but like
no exceptions the rule of not inventing
anything you're not supposed to invent
anything when you put it in the standard
right you have to cleave as closely as
possible to existing practice
and we kind of did and kind of didn't
right there's some new things that come
in there that didn't show up in any
other languages and there's some things
that were had lots of existing practice
that existed in a lot of different other
places um but this this was kind of
Martin's kind of saying like we need to
pump the brakes and kind of look at what
we're standardizing and what we're doing
in the standard right of course it
wasn't just inside the committee it was
outside the committee right this is a uh
paper called how isoc became unusable
for operating system development which
is
just a fantastic paper title um but the
contention that Victor has is that
because of the things that people are
doing with undefined behavior in
particular
and the way that compilers are
optimizing code these days under the
rules of
isoc that makes it less suitable for
doing actual operating systems work or
other systems programming lowlevel work
tasks um and so that was Victor's
contention when he wrote this paper he
shipped it out in January um I I guess I
wouldn't say he's outside the committee
because like he did show up for like a
time he was like there and then he kind
of he was there for a while he kind of
observed watched
participated um
got on a lot of people's nerves um
publicly not this is not like private he
did did that publicly unfortunately um
and then he kind of left and then
published his paper um and so kind of
the contention of his paper was that you
know if you're going to be writing for
operating system whatever you're not
really writing ISO C you're writing you
know some special flavor of C right that
is you know chalk full of compiler Flags
like so uh you know you want to have
flags that you know well with
well-defined over uh well-defined rap on
over flow right um you want to have
flags that don't uh that prevent the
compiler from doing things like deleting
null pointer checks if you use a
standard Library function because stand
all standard Library functions do not
have do not accept null pointers as an
input and it's undefined Behavior to
give give standard Library functions
from c n pointer so if you give it a n
if you give it a pointer and then you
try to check after that function that
null pointer the compiler will just
delete that check because like it's not
supposed to happen right you're never
supposed to give a n pointer to stir
copy to whatever right um or mem copy or
similar to that and that actually did
eventually result in some
vulnerabilities in certain places um
because again a lot of people like to
pair null pointer with a size of zero
rather than like some funky pointer that
like is of size zero with size zero um
and so naturally when people were just
writing normal code that happen to have
no point plus zero you know you you
delete some checks and suddenly you're
scribbling over the bootloader of your
very important modem or device or small
thing that's supposed to make sure you
don't crash um and that's not
good so that's the perspective of this
paper right it talked about undefined
Behavior it talked about from the
perspective outside rather than like are
we standardizing things correctly this
was the things you were standardizing do
not help us as systems programmers right
and so this was a different perspective
then there was yet a third perspective
unfortunately also negative um that c23
was basically a I wouldn't say dumpster
fire he didn't quite call it dumpster
fire because he does praise certain
things but he you know he says that you
know standardization is the The Whiskey
Tango Fox Trot which is you know just a
fancy way of saying WTF which is you
know what the exactly um and so again
Terence Kelly and uh Mr Pon wrote this
paper cash 23 the new C standard sets
the world on fire right and in this when
they lambasted a lot of different things
that did and didn't go into the standard
right like so real loock becoming
undefined Behavior was a particularly
fun Target that came out of this paper
um and a bunch of other stuff that we
changed in c23 that I'm also going to
have to talk about uh as we go
forward so that's a lot that's a lot of
negativity um you know um I of course
write a lot of positive stuff so I'll
kind of be focusing on the negatives um
so this talk might be a little bit
depressing about c23 um but we're going
to kind of talk about talk through a lot
of that negativity and like what's
what's what and how we can kind of
approach it
really so the first thing we have to ask
is are we failing right basic question
to ask are we failing in our mission
right we have a charter we have a set of
principles right we're supposed to
codify existing practice we're supposed
to trust a programmer except when it
comes to security stuff we're supposed
to uh make sure that we you know give
them the tools they need to get the job
done it the code can be both portable
and non portable right um you
know where did things go wrong right
where are we going wrong what are we
doing wrong right
if or is it maybe the charter that's
fails right do we not have the right set
of principles are we guiding ourselves
in the wrong direction ction and that's
why we keep making you know what people
consider to be mistakes
right and we have to ask ourselves like
know is the spirit of seed like dying
right is this this idea of a simple
small language that you know can be
compiled by everybody but has like this
Universal appeal and that works
everywhere right is is that Spirit going
away are we losing it right with c23 are
we losing what made see good right and
are we going to keep losing it as we
keep kind of chasing features and fixes
and whatever else
right so so that's kind of the biger
question around all of this right are we
actually doing something proper in
service of sea and this is this is the
spirit of SE gets thrown at me all the
time right um it doesn't matter what
discussion I'm in um new feature old
feature bug fix talking about undefined
Behavior right I always hear about the
spirit of sea like you know it's like
the the Ghost of Christmas Past come to
tell me about you know how evil and and
scroogie I am but you
know obviously we have these you know
these these principles right you know
you're you're supposed to you know don't
for the program from doing what needs to
be done keep the language small and
simple right this is supposed to be the
spirit of sea this is literally there's
a heading called the spirit of sea and
then this comes after it right so a
through F this is what's in the spirit
of sea right this is what the charter
says Spirit of sea is right and of
course they people you know take and
take one of these lines and slap me over
the head with it whenever I write a
proposal or something and that's usually
what you know they say this spirit is
supposed to be about um so obviously
right there are the full set of
principles I showed you a glimpse of
them before but really um c89 we had
existing code is important C code can be
portable C code can be non-portable
those two sound contradictory but the
idea is that you know there's some stuff
that can be portable and then there's
other stuff where you just have to let
the vendor make an extension and you
can't really you know I can't really
properly describe your bus memory with
your you know uh chip memory and all
that stuff correctly I'm just going to
assume that's all unified address space
but like you know you can write some
things that might be non-portable that
will talk to the fact that they'll know
the fact that you are dealing with
several different address spaces right
um so obviously the ports that are
portable are the stuff that we Define
the stuff that's non-portable is
undefined behavior and you know
implementation defined behavior and
unspecified Behavior three different
kinds
of traps for you to run into and then
your vendor extensions that go all
around that
um obviously want to avoid quiet changes
so when we break something we want to
make sure that it's compile time break
so we don't like you know change
something and then like your code just
silently does something different and
then everything explodes right that's
you know that's bad um obviously we have
the treaty between the Implement and the
programmer right you every time you
compile the programmer you basically
shake the hand of your implementor and
they say good luck and you say thank you
and then you hope that you know you get
a good program on the other side um
that's part of it um obviously it says
keep the spirit of C which references
that list um and then c99 we had support
International programming that was when
everybody was like on the like posix and
local kick and so like we put that in
there we put a bunch of like local and
like Global mutable State and everybody
was happy until we started sharing stuff
and then everybody was sad because you
know you called the library function and
it changed the local of something or
mess with the local and so this like
Library all the way over here that
didn't have anything to do with you um
is broken now because you changed to
using the uh comma for your decimal
point and that was expecting a period
and now everything's gone to hell um and
so a little bit iffy but we do have
support
International programming um codify
existing practice to address evident
deficiencies right so always focusing on
existing
practice more principles right um so
there're about 15 so in c99 we continued
with that we got minimizing
compatibility with c89 minimiz Inc
compatibility with C++ maintain
conceptual Simplicity and then C1 we
added some more right we had trust a
programmer but that's kind of outdated
you know because security and we're
getting our butts kicked in you know uh
in in in all of these uh C databases um
we uh wanted to say that you know there
should be no invention without exception
that's very important right we're not
supposed to do anything unless a
compiler vendor does it first right so
they got to do it first and then then we
follow what they do you know and no no
inventing stuff no making new features
none of that um you know obviously we
have to talk about migration of existing
codebase you have to make sure that you
know if you have a c89 Cod base you can
Port it to C 11 or even to
c23 not quite
fully possible without some tweaks but
we I think we did a decent job there and
then c23 obviously you're
self-documenting applications um but
more than the principles of the
charter it's used in Internet arguments
a lot um and in committee arguments a
lot I get to hear the word the spirit of
SE so much uh to the point that it
actually drives me insane every time I
hear it I just like want to take off the
headphones I just want to like just just
just God I don't want to hear this but I
have to hear it um this this is the the
phras that gets thrown at me so much
this isn't in line with the spirit of
sea and I just I
just God um it's a very common cudel
right
but why is it a common cudel why does it
keep showing up why do people keep
telling me that this isn't in line with
C right when we talk about defer I keep
hearing that oh this is garbage and it
is in line with c and you know uh you
know you should have to keep the
language small and simple right when we
hear about conix sper we hear oh it's
not in line with C it's erasing um the
ability for compiler do optimizations at
compile time or run time whatever it
wants to you shouldn't be able to do
that it's not in line with the spirit of
C right um almost every feature vas
complex imaginary uh a lot of Library
functions right all of them is this in
the spirit of sea somebody always says
no and it gets confusing like who are
you supposed to be trusting here right
because sometimes they say no to stuff
that looks like they should say yes to
it and sometimes say yes stuff that you
think they should they would say no to
and it doesn't seem like there's any
consistency and it drives me nuts um but
I hear it a lot the spirit of sea again
father Christmas bothering me
um it gets applied to everything
literally everything right new stuff old
stuff stuff we put in c23 stuff that was
there a long time ago right um you know
if you use generic you know you should
be fired right that c of thing right con
complex shouldn't have been there embed
didn't didn't need to be put in lambdas
shouldn't be put in right um why do we
have a atomics when we have volatile
right which is which was a very fun
discussion and by fun I mean depressing
you know obviously you know atomics were
not in the spirit of sea the way we
standardized them right
um
and
that whole conversation drove me
absolutely up the wall
um you know and the reason some of these
have Aster there is that we actually
only started saying this after we
adopted the feature right
and after we saw that it wasn't picked
up very quickly in the ecosystem so we
kind of it's like an it's like it's it's
an expost facto justification like oh it
didn't get good adoption must not have
been in the spirit of sea we should roll
it back and in some cases we did right
variable length arrays complex imaginary
and a couple of other things when were
standardized in c99 they were made
mandatory features in c99 but when C11
came around we kind of rolled a lot of
them back and made them optional um and
again this was idea because well
adoption is slow and you know they're
not really seeing that the
implementations might not be good right
along this time we were also getting a
lot of you know vulnerabilities off of
the stack thanks FAS um where people
would you know un not take an
unsanitized number and use it as the
runtime parameter into an array and that
created a VA that would either blow up
your stack or manage it in the way you
didn't expect and things would go wrong
very quickly um you know and so a lot of
people had misgiving about things like
variable length arrays and other things
and so kind of retroactively after they
were standardized to kind of put us on
par with APL and Fortran as like
numerical Computing languages we then
rolled it back and said e it's optional
you can you can you can throw it out
right and so a lot of compilers do throw
it out msvc in particular throws it
right out the
window so you know obviously we want to
adhere to this chart right when there's
a document that tells us what we're
supposed to be doing you know everybody
says that we're abandoning the spirit of
sea or that we're doing we're adding
complexity where you know we don't have
enough user experience or commercial
compiler experience it has to be a
commercial compiler by the way you can't
just like Tinker some compiler yourself
they put a clause in it needs to be a
commercial compil so you got to get you
to be getting paid for it which sucks
because I'm not getting paid for a lot
the work I do um unless I can swing my
GitHub sponsors as payment for the I
don't know I'll figure out how to make
it a I'll make my implementation a
commercial implementation I'll figure it
out but it has to be a commercial
compiler um that has the experience with
these features you can't be too
inventive obviously and you know you
can't be using new features for all the
stuff that we've been doing above right
so how do we adhere to this this this
this this this document ah how do we
make sure that we're hearing to the
standard how do we make sure that we're
pleasing people who you know kind of
have been for a very long time saying
you're ruining C you're ruining C you're
ruining C you're ruining C you're
ruining c
um so let's talk about some of those
features right because like if we're
going to say that vas or threads or
atomics or generics ruin C right we have
to find where we failed the charter
right right that would be a good place
to start right so that we know where we
failed so that we can you know stop
failing right like it's like a
postmortem sort of deal right although
it's not dead so postmortem isn't right
the exact right term but like we're
gonna we're going to do a little small
dissection right yeah
um so variable length arrays and
variably modifies types vmts um this was
actually originally proposed by a man by
the name of Tom McDonald on behalf of
cig cig CNC plus cray research um some
of you might have never heard of them
but if you're in the numeric world
they're all over the place because they
are huge National Labs um and they're
also huge in you know not just National
Labs in the United States but Labs all
over the world um they were the ones who
cooked up vas right as we know them
today right they made the feature right
back in what is it 1994 1994
um and I kind of have some check boxes
here about things they kind of adhere to
the c99 princip principles right that
were there at the time so you know they
had three years of secret proposals and
editing so there was lots of back and
forth made sure everybody was in in eror
they didn't really Rush the process um
they were trusting the programmer right
I mean it's vas right you're typically
supposed to allocate something on the
stack so like you're responsible don't
blow out your stack don't you know
connect it to unsanitized user input
right all that stuff right we are
trusting the programmer right that
turned out to be a mistake in some cases
but like we were following the charter
um it was implemented in multiple
compilers right so this wasn't pure
invention where somebody just said I
have an idea and just like scribbled it
on the back of the napkin and like
folded it up and then like mailed it
into ISO um this was actually
implemented in place right so obviously
c c and C++ had it but then the EG this
was around the time when there was the I
wouldn't say violent but there was the
explosive split between GCC and EGCC um
where they parted ways from one another
right they forked GCC at a time um and
so for a while there was
like it wasn't quite red hat but it was
basically red hsh folk who forked GCC
and basically maintained their own
version and vastly improved it and they
improved it so well that it was around
that time around the 2.x DAT I think 2.8
2.9 2.95 they merged back into the GC
main Tre and they became the like the
actual stewards of GCC right um so that
was where and around that time they also
had support for VAs right um and there
were other compilers as well that also
had support fre so we have multiple
commercial widely used implementations
right so we're we're following the chart
over now some things that people want to
ding it on is that it's not simple right
it's runtime right so you've taken size
of which is originally a compile time
thing a constant time number right that
you can use in various different places
that require integer constant
expressions and it would work right it
would give you you know statically sized
arrays you could you know use it in in
certain computations and it would do
exactly what you would expect it to um
then we chy to change it to the this
runtime thing right so you have the same
syntax everything looks the same but it
has subtly different properties um
and the other issue and this is kind of
post after the standardization of vas it
mess poorly with existing implementation
so a lot of impation didn't have a lot
of Stack to give and a lot of impation
didn't have a heap so where is this
runtime data coming from and the
standard was very quiet about that right
we don't really say where this memory is
supposed to come from right is a
conforming implementation that you can
pull vaa memory off of the Heap every
time you can just call Malo every time
and then call free at the end of the
block and like that's valid that's a
valid implementation um I wouldn't
recommend it but like go for it
um so it meshed poorly with existing
implementation a lot of people had
trouble implementing it and they also
struggled with suddenly having this
runtime size of and consequentially down
the line as we got things like a line of
and other things that we're supposed to
like compute the you know things at
compile time time those things became
runtime entities when you put vas with
them right and so this became kind of
like a very big contention Point like it
felt clunky to use and not everybody was
Implement correctly and you know what
was it it wasn't until 2020 that GCC
actually implemented what's called stack
probing which is really just check the
size of the stack before you decide to
allocate this this huge buffer off of
the stack so you don't like blow up the
stack right so it'll seg fault instead
of just like going off into space um
and
so you know it took a long time for
impation to get kind of even remotely
decent with vas and
so that had a very negative impact on a
lot of people who were using it right so
they noticed the code gen was bad they
noticed that a lot of the features were
just not up to Snuff and so it kind of
contributed this nasty feedback cycle
where everybody was like V they want to
use vas but like they have this bad code
gen and you know it's difficult to
control where the memory comes from and
how does your implementation implement M
the the feature right I don't have any
control over this so I just had to
depend on my implement but what if my
implementor not necessarily hostile to
me but they kind of phoned it in and
they just they did whatever right and
they didn't add any of the bells and
whistles that I needed right and so it
obviously uh uh it was obviously
difficult right a difficult time for a
lot of people um the numerical people
were happy though because again they
exist on their own planet in their own
island with their own supercomputers
they get their own compilers they can
hack them up as much as they want to um
so they were partying right they were
like yeah vas we got it we got vmts we
got vas we're on they're on Cloud9 right
um
but this is kind of what V look like and
honestly it kind of checked all the
boxes right except for the runtime size
of bit but even then this was back in
like n this was back in 94 right like
compilers were barely doing constant
propagation back then right like do you
really need a constant time size of I
mean it turned out to be super important
later as we got like better compilers
that could do better optimizations but
like I mean do did you really need it
and so it turned out yes we did need it
it was kind of an important property um
but you know we degraded into this
runtime size of and all these
interesting questions about when the
type of vaa is made available and
whatnot to to the end user and so that
kind of became a point but like for the
most part this passes like what the
charter asked of it right so even though
retroactively we say it was a bad
feature right like at the time it it
checked boxes it checked the boxes it
had all it had the implementations we
knew how to implement it right that sort
of stuff
right threads
threads. actually proposed back in 2005
um had a lot of experience which is
weird because when you read some of the
papers especially Martin seor is like oh
there's only like one implementation of
it and like they didn't know what they
were doing and we standardize you know
unbaked stuff right um but it turns out
it was actually well implemented it was
actually in fact a joint effort between
wg21 and wg4 it was around this time
that like both C and C++ both committees
were like swapping papers back and forth
they were really talking to each other a
lot like almost every meeting every
every time right um and so they did this
kind of together right um and it was
implemented and Deployable on multiple
platforms now we didn't get threads.
exactly right but we got X threads. on
MSC Windows because Windows can't help
themselves and can't be standard with
anything um
and we got obviously a form of it based
on lib P threads now the LI P threads
version was a little bit late to the
party um when this first got proposed
and eventually standardized in C11 um
the thread studies didn't come for like
what another six years on GCC um they
could have implemented it but I think
there just wasn't any pressure because
they weren't really doing much code
sharing and everybody was using Li P
threads um P threads was basically the
way to do threading on anytime you want
touch the nxs machine um so it didn't
really manifest very quickly um and so
it didn't see much use um and so at the
bottom there you can see not implemented
by by most vendors it was be because of
this idea that you know GCC took such a
long time to implement it Microsoft
still hasn't implemented it though I've
been told on the down low that they're
implementing threads. H and maybe
they'll get it in their compiler
eventually um which would be great for
msvc um but it's not implemented yet
um but it was very much a collaboration
between a lot of different people from
both C and C++ there was a lot of
implementation experience there was a
lot of eyes on it so this wasn't quite
Half Baked it just you know we had all
the buyin we had all the people there we
standardized it and then it took such a
long time to actually get off the ground
right and so and that and that's a
little bit weird right it's sort of the
same story with vas right like we
standardized it we knew what we were
supposed to be doing and then people
kind of stumbled a lot in implementing
it and getting it on platforms right um
and so it was a bit of a weird thing
right like we had the standard thread
facility that almost nobody was using
because they would rather just hit the
plat they'd rather just hit the platform
specific API to do it right or in some
cases some people would literally wrap
c++'s stood thread and use that to
create their own platform agnostic API
which is just like
what huh um but that's what we got um so
that was kind of the trouble with thread
and again it was mentioned by a couple
papers it was mentioned by a couple
people that like this was like a reason
this like a one thing that we failed to
do properly in C11 um but again they
kind of did everything right right they
had the Droid enfort they had the
multiple Deployable implementations they
had all the stuff that would qualify it
as a feature for C but kind of again
retroactively we say it was a bad
feature right um and it seemed most of
that stem from the fact that it just
wasn't implemented by our
vendors atomics this one's super fun and
by fun I mean painful um lots of talk
about this one right this one spent more
time baking than thread stuff the thread
stuff kind of came with the the the
atomics um but the atomics were the
really big part because at this time
this is when everybody was like losing
their minds about the memory model in
C++ right they weren't able to like
there's no well- defined way to like
talk between threads data races how do
you share stuff right and so in C11 and
and C++ 11 and later iterations of C++
they really hammered down on the memory
model like what does it mean to have a
data Ras what is happens what is that
happens before relationship for our code
right how do you you know Define reorder
reordering optimizations and so on and
so forth right um so
originally this was implemented as a
library at first right this was what
like Hans and Lawrence and and Paul
McKinny who's a prolific uh Linn kernel
contributor Crowley obviously does a
whole bunch of numeric stuff and lots of
asynchronous work um and Hans is just
again a a Titan of just uh
multi-threaded programming
multi-threaded modeling and everything
right he powered a lot of the work to
get this a this model for
multi-threading into the standard right
um and so you have all these Powerhouse
people working together they implement
the stuff they share their
implementation they share their notes
they're sharing between C and C++ making
sure that everybody's up to date um but
one of the things that they actually
discovered which is what you're supposed
to do right when you're doing when
you're getting user experience by
testing stuff in the field they tested
the fact that they had these libraries
and they would deploy these libraries
and then the compiler would reorder
their crap on them right and like that
that's not that's not supposed to happen
right you're not supposed to have a
compiler that reordering your atomics
Beyond its fences and everything else
right and the reason it was reordering
things Beyond its fences is because the
compiler didn't understand that like
this was like a fence and I'm not
supposed to do that right so there was
always this game of cat and mouse where
they would deploy the library and then
the compiler would be like Oh I'm
smarter now and then they would start
reordering stuff again and they like no
no stop doing that and so what
eventually ended up happening is that
especially for uh the C stand for the C
standard committee right because again
they don't have the same kind of
commitment to overpowered Library
features like C++ does um they said
listen we can't kind of keep playing
this cat and mouse game we have to give
the compiler a set of things that it
knows about for sure so that it doesn't
do things like reorder fences or
anything else right so we have to bless
certain things bless certain operations
bless certain types as atomic as having
these properties so that we can get the
ordering guarantees that we wanted in
the first place right and so that's why
this thing that was started as a library
had the transition into the compiler
right but that's invention right so
people like freaked out like whoa hold
on you're doing invention here we
shouldn't be doing that but they explain
themselves at the time like listen like
if you do this as a library you're going
to be forever playing this game of cat
and mouse or you're going to have to
request built-in from your compiler
anyway so they stop reordering your
stuff like at some point the compiler
has to be aware of what's going on you
can't just do this as a library forever
right and so that's why it
became something built into the C
language right
now unfortunately that caused a lot of
issues right um a lot of people want the
atomics that happen in C to match up
kind of pretty perfectly with the ones
that happened in
C++ and it turns out that a lot of
implementations weren't really
communicating with other like GBC wasn't
talking to liod C++ when they Implement
their atomics or whatever right um and
so there was cases where you would
attempt to use a uh uh an atomic int
from C and you'd pass it to a stood
Atomic of int to uh C++ and it was not
ABI compatible it was not compatible in
any way shape or form and so things just
broke in horrific ways um and it meant
that you couldn't mix C and cs plus code
so now we have a compatibility issue
right so you have C code that you want
to write atomics with and then you have
C++ code that has atomics and you can't
mix the two right you have to like
serialize and Bridge and that's
obviously slow because you're trying to
use Atomic trying to go fast trying to
you know reduce contention but now you
have have to introduce these manual sync
points to make sure that you're doing
things the right way right to sync
between the two languages and so usually
what happened is somebody either
completely abandoned C++ atomics and
went with the c1s or completely
abandoned the C++ atomics and went with
the c uh C++ atomics and went with the
the c1s or or vice
versa so that was a pain um we also of
course had a little bit of a usability
issue with the way we made them types in
C so you can be a qualifier you can
atomically qualify a type or you can
actually make a type out of it by doing
underscore Atomic and then putting the
type in the parentheses um and these are
supposed to be like identical is but uh
you know it has
interesting being a qualifier means it
has it's being a qualifier means it's
it's it's like const or volatile right
and that's not great when you're doing
certain kinds of programming right um
and it also kind of violates the mental
model that some people have about like I
can drop qualifiers or I can gain
qualifiers right and so it didn't
actually work like that so this
qualifier version sort of made it
difficult for some people program but
other people loved it right particularly
numerical people because they wanted to
do something like saycore Atomic in Star
and say this is a atomic uh this is a
pointer to an atomic integer right and
they want to basically access it like
it's an atomic um and so for them that
was really good and they wanted like
lots of ABI there was a lot of people
who wanted a lot of different kinds of
ABI uh Styles right and so typically
what the two different ABI Styles you
could have would be Lock Free atomics
where the CPUs uh the CPU can guarantee
that if any operation that you're doing
on say an integer or a car or a double
or not maybe not double but whatever um
could be guaranteed to be done in a
certain amount of time that would always
happen right either happen or doesn't
happen right so either you observe it
before it happens or You observe it
after happen and there's no like racing
there um the other approach is obviously
not lock free right there's a lock
inside right so there's a type you have
the actual value stored in there and
then you have a lock next to it or you
have a lock table stored next nearby
somewhere and so the whole Point um is
that there were mismatches between C and
C++ there were mismatches even
internally in implementations um about
whether they were lock free or not and
that prevented a lot of people from
sharing the stuff and you know obviously
you have if you have a lock based
implementation it could be a little bit
slower than a lock free one and so some
people wanted to be able to do things
like oh if I have an inar just a plain
pointer to instar of a bunch of data I
want to be able to make an atomic point
of that and then access each integer
atomically and like did that work was
that supposed to work right depends if
it's lock free or not and so it was hard
to kind of guarantee that stuff and so
that's why atomic was kind of really
rough for the usability um which was
strange because we didn't catch this
even though some of the stuff was
implemented we didn't kind of catch that
and you probably wouldn't be able to
catch it until much later right because
it's not
something whether or not your type is
Lock Free is very much a platform
dependent choice and you only really
figure that out until you like get down
to the platform and you start mixing and
matching and doing lots of big code um
and so even though they had like between
them implementation experience between
their compilers like they were all
self-consistent right when you start
handing it off to vendors they can do
whatever they want and again again
quality of implementation right so they
could be Lock Free they could be not
lock free and so
vendors freely mixed and matched for
whatever they could get out of their
platform right and sometimes they made
suboptimal choices but because of
application uh uh because of the
application binary interface ABI um they
couldn't change their implementation so
even their suboptimal it's like well we
got to keep it because we got to make
sure that we're stable you know if some
you take some you know C11 code and a
composite with c23 even if we know
better than the c23 code like we can't
change to a lock free implementation
because our ABI is just like that right
and so you have all these issues
surrounding atomics that despite kind of
passing the initial muster and kind of
being a ready feature as far as C11 uh
was concerned um still ended up failing
kind of in the final leg because of
these compatibility issues right and
again it's not it's hard to not it's
hard to see that coming when you know
you're with your you're with your people
who know what they're doing and then you
kind of fan out and you go to Exotic
platforms and you go to different places
that you don't you know have full
control over and now things don't quite
pan out the way you expected to right
and so that was kind of a large
motivation what was going on
there oh I went too far um generic also
called out as a terrible feature that
you should get fired for um but this was
actually originally conceived by uh PJ
plugger who also worked on you know one
of the most I guess well-known stls the
dware STL um which got used in a lot of
different places and was actually bought
by Microsoft and it's actually was the
foundation of their STL that is
currently in the GitHub
repository
um it was sourced from existing practice
but it wasn't exactly the same as
existing practice right so GC had this
thing called built-in choose expression
where you would give an expression then
you start listing out some types and it'
kind of be like an if tree where um you
say if it's this type then do this
otherwise if it's this type do that
right um gener generic the way it works
is it's kind of more like a switch
statement you say here's all the types
and you only match one of them right um
so it's a little bit different than
built-in choose expression
um it was picked up and implemented and
the reason it was picked up and
implemented by EDG I think possibly
Intel at the time um was because they
were having trouble implementing what
was called type generic macros which
we'll talk about in a second um but they
basically proved it could work and it
could solve the problem without
introducing C templates or function
overloading at the time there were a lot
of math fun that they were adding to C
um if you ever looked at the the like
annx f or anx H you'll see like a
million different like floating Point
functions in fact for c23 we added like
what was it over 500
new math like floating Point math
functions um but there's a lot of those
functions and so a lot of people want
easier ways to program that stuff um and
so they came up with this idea of type
generic macros and kind of on the behind
for some of this what they were doing is
they were abusing function overloading
right which is a feature that comes from
C++ and it's not really in see but they
kind of said well we're just going to
standardize these macros and you'll put
the arguments in there and then you know
through some magic we'll know we'll know
whether they call the float version the
double version or the long version or
the long double version or whatever
um and so that's kind of what happened
there um so it was implemented it did
have existing practice there was a
slight bit of invention obviously going
from built and choose expression which
was more like an if Cascade to generic
um but they proved it could work and
they was able to do it without
introducing templates into C and or
function overloading right which was
kind of the main driver right they
didn't want to the they the committee
explicitly rejected overloading um fun
or that kind of overloading as a
solution for C right um so they had to
do something else right this was like
then again to kind of talk about this
right this was the TG math header right
the type generic math header
um this was part of technical
specification right so again they use
this technical specification mechanism a
TS right they can ship things out in the
world through this document early before
the standard goes and get experience
with it so they got all this experience
with it they understood what the TG math
is but the overloading features were
rejected before but the TG math was
still kind of going through the
committee right and they wanted it so
they said okay we need generic right and
so that's this is kind of where generic
was born in the first place right um
there's actually some very there's some
very interesting papers where people are
like Hey so uh I'm trying to implement
your generic this generic function thing
and I can't because there's no mechanism
to do it in C and normally that's okay
because one of the things we say in the
committee is that it's okay if your
library performs magic right um your
implementor is allowed to perform magic
right so for example in offset of you
can take a old pointer and create a
pointer to something and then go to the
member inside that no pointer and then
subtract that from no pointer to get the
offset to the member inside the thing
right and that's like that's like the
favorite that's like a favorite language
lawyer question right you go to stack
Overflow you ask about offset of it's
like can I Implement offset of and
standard C and they get like a
millionaire is like no you can't yes you
can no close we already entered this
before right you know all that stuff um
but
like your library is allowed to do magic
right um but this was too much magic and
it was more than most implementation can
handle and so that's why they needed
generic right they needed a way of
saying listen if you give me a float I
will call the float version of cosine
right if you give me a double I'm going
to call the double version and so on and
so forth right and then you know you get
you know these these quadratic versions
where you know you're passing two
arguments and you have to pick the right
one and it's very fun
um but that's where generic came from
that's where TG math came from right and
again these were things that were
implemented and shipped and so nobody's
really violating the charter with any of
this right they're they're kind of
having to do a little bit of invention
which is a a violation of the charter
but like it's in service of these
features right and you're supposed to
allow to balance the idea and they did
Implement generic before they actually
standardized it so like they kind of
checked all the boxes
right and so what what we're really
seeing is that maybe these features were
not all that illc conceived right like
sure it's not like don't get me wrong
like vas are not my favorite feature and
neither is generic and a bunch of other
stuff that's in the see but like these
things didn't violate the charter right
like they weren't doing the wrong thing
they weren't making the wrong choices
when they were doing this right they
were following all the rules in so far
as they could follow all the rules for
being put in imposs situations like the
committee is committing is considering
some kind of overloading and then kind
of swaps it out from under you while
you're trying to standardize your your
your well-considered stuff so you know
maybe it wasn't the features that were
ill conceives right again not that there
aren't room for some improvements in
this
stuff you know for example vas and vmts
have a lot of holes right so this syntax
looks super ugly don't worry about it um
but basically what I'm doing here is I'm
passing two sizes and then I'm using
those sizes to create a pointer to VA
right and the reason I'm creating a
pointer to VA is because I want this
pointer to VA this this variably
modified type to hold its size right and
the idea is that if I use size of star P
right it's a runtime thing because again
it's a it's a variably modified type I
can get the size out of this right
without consulting M or n right
directly and so this seems like hold on
does this mean that we have bounce
checked arrays like arrays we can do
bounce checking or poters where we can
do bounce checking and C right like that
that would be pretty cool right right
except not
quite I have Nal 2 and m equal 3 right I
put them in a vaa and I create uh a
pointer to vaa right I maloc my vaa
right and this is how I get a variably
modified type I just get a pointer to a
VA right and so you can maloc these
right um this is again probably blowing
certain people's mind numerical people
are all up on this stuff but this is the
stuff they don't tell you about that
they're using all the time um but you
can malop this right so I now I have a
pointer to an array that contains its
own size right so if I printf the size
right that's that first print is 24 if I
print aay size and I pass in n and M
unmodified I get 24 right so like it's
contain the size properly I then modify
M to be
four I then print half the size from
locally right just directly referencing
p and I get 24 I then ask to print the
array size and now the size is
32 and this is where vmts fall in their
face this is where vas fall on their
face you can lie about them which is
fair because you can lie about any
pointer in C but like this I thought
this was going to be like the holy gra
like oh finally I have a sized pointer I
can do something with this I can make
something happen with this I can put
some safety in some code bases or
something right and I can but only if
people don't lie but like the entire
point of things like heart bleed was
that it lied about about the size it was
a mistake they didn't mean to but it
lied about the size of the pointer and
then they just read a bunch of stuff
they weren't supposed to like
everybody's secrets and then dumped them
out to attackers and then they had
access to
everything so vas didn't learn the
lesson right we still get to lie right
and so we're like this close like we
could have a syntax where like because
you because you can see this right even
though I modify M and N in this
function I print for the print locally
for p it's still 24 so like the size is
stored in the vaa this the VA knows its
size so but when I pass to a function
it's just like well I'm going to throw
that size out the window and then I get
32 or 800 and now I'm reading data I'm
not supposed to right now I'm accessing
things I'm not supposed to and
that's emblematic of C right you know
you pass an array somewhere it decays to
a pointer where' the size go who knows
um and so this was this was this close
to being like the solution for stuff and
then it stop being the solution for
stuff but again this is what I say when
there's there's room for improvement for
some of these features right there's
room to make them better and we haven't
quite utilized ourselves to do that
yet similarly uh generic loses
qualifiers and array information right
so if I have a constant n and I want a
generic on it and I say oh I know this
is a const n I'm going to match on the
fact that it's constant in N um that
doesn't work if you're on clang or GCC
like Mo a recent version it'll warn you
and say this Branch this Con in Branch
will never be reached because when you
do generic it strips off qualifiers and
it strips off array information so
arrays will Decay into like pointers
or yes I think so someone double check
me on that they decay in the poins right
probably yeah I mean it's
I think you might be able to match
specifically on the exact size of an
array but I think it might also just it
might it might just Decay um
but oh yeah there is a pointer
conversion okay yeah because right it
performs L value conversion which the
same thing that is happens on when you
pass things to a function call yes sorry
that was nerd speake for uh it decays
um but you can't do this right you can't
match on the fact that it's constant n
it strips out those qualifiers so like
you can't match all that stuff right so
if I wanted to implement say uh is const
or is a ray or is some some other kind
of way of implementing this um I just
can't do that
uh you know I will just get return one
I'll just get one here the will return
one and then we'll just kind of go on on
our lives so we lose the ability to do
some kind of very cool matching and
stuff that normally we would uh be able
to do in maybe other languages or if
generic was a little bit better than it
is fun fact Aon Balman isn't here but
Aaron Balman actually implemented a
version of generic where if you wrap
this n in type of which I standardized
for c23 so it's now actually you can use
it everywhere assuming msvc catches up
um you can wrap that in type of and then
they have an extension where because you
passing a type into generic it will
actually keep the qualifiers and keep
the array and not do L value Decay so
fun little for all of you who are here
you get this a fun little clang secret
and that you could that's when you can
start doing like is constant do it like
normally and cool and stuff like that
but that's that's like Advanced like C
meta programming and like that's
something i' you know I'd give a talk on
or something
later um th obviously we're talking
about it weakness it's not everywhere um
it's not on Microsoft Visual c and a few
POS based platforms don't have it
because they just say well I have P
threads I don't need this threads. H
nonsense and then you know you you write
code and then it just fails because they
don't have it um even if it's perfectly
capable of being on that platform um and
so that kind of suffers in that way
there's also other existential problems
right enumerations cannot be size
controlled right um undefined Behavior
obviously continues to punch people in
the face um we're actually not
standardizing a lot of existing
extensions in practice so like statement
Expressions really cool stuff nested
functions and blocks really cool stuff
that we haven't standardized right um
there's also ABI problems right so the
32-bit time and specifically the 2038
problem right it's not necessarily like
oh we need to use 64-bit time that if we
change the 64bit time we break every
program that was depending on time te
being a 32-bit value right um and so we
need to be able to do things like fix
the application binary interface be able
to patch those binary interface without
blowing up the old code and we don't
really have any tools to do that which
hilariously um other platforms have
already figured out how to do this since
like 25 years ago um BSD has a way of
solving ABI and they solve this problem
it's literally it's literally an example
on their Wei on like yeah this is how we
solved this problem like 25 years ago
and I wish people would solve it in the
standard um and we haven't done that yet
so again more existential crisis in the
standard
um and so you know it's 2023 right so
where's our portable bit function right
where's our simd where like C is build
as this access to the hardware language
right even though it's it's supposed to
just be a normal high level abstract
machine right it's build as accs to the
hardware the fast language the dangerous
language you could do all the cool stuff
okay but I can't even like I can't even
use my xsm xmm registers right like
you know I can't even do uh uh a
portable bit packing on my structures
right without you know getting a drink
getting a manual and then you know
praying a tribute packed or pragma
packed one or whatever gets the job done
with all the crazy bit stuff which you
would think that this is such a old
problem that it would be solved by now
but there's compilers that pack things
differently than like GCC or mscc or
whatever else right so not piling on
this implementor he implemented it the
way he did for a good reason but secc
does things differently than GCC and
that has actually resulted in a lot of
people like hey I'm compiling for libu
I'm trying to compile something for lib
USB and I have this structure and I'm
trying to put it on the wire so it goes
to my USB device and it actually is not
correct and it's like well it's because
we do different packing for our
structure even if you use a tribute
packed even if you use these bit fields
that uh is different from GCC and that
person is effectively up you know bleep
creek without a paddle because
you know it's just implementation to
find what happens with your structure
right um where do the bits go uh who
controls those bits uh right like it's
just whatever the implementation decides
to do or feels like doing that day right
and we haven't solved that problem right
which is really weird because the Ada
programming language solved this problem
like in the 80s and like we just we keep
like we keep like writing papers like H
how are we going to solve this very
difficult tough problem and it's like
just look at the language right there um
but we don't do do that unic code
conversion functions obviously I'm a
text guy that's how I actually ended up
getting down to C in the first place um
I was asking too many questions about
local and text and I ended up down here
and I'm the product editor um so Unicode
not even once um but Unicode conversion
functions are something we don't have um
and that's kind of my fault it was
supposed to be in c23 but I didn't get
it in in time um and then of course we
have a whole gaggle of posix style
functions that kind of affect global
mutable State um you know we want to be
able to call is upper and have it kind
of be consistent you usually think it'd
be asky or something right but you know
it changes based on the local and so you
get different kinds of behaviors and
performance characteristics from is
upper and things like that right because
it's tied to the
local and so that's all kind of
controlled by global shared mutable data
right that implies locks that implies
you know bottlenecks in your algorithms
and whatever else and so now you're kind
of suffering and so again it's 2023 and
like where where is the stuff that would
make this all easier right
um why haven't this stuff been Sol why
haven't we gotten to a place where this
all is kind of cleaned up and makes
sense and if we're relying on
standardizing existing practice
right and existing practice in many of
these cases like for the ABI from
FreeBSD and other places has fixed this
stuff like why haven't we actually gone
and done it um and that kind of calls
into question the charter right
like so I had to get my hands dirty
right so re23 right this is the first
standard release I've been a part of
right so I started doing things to get
involved right and that's that's how I
got like again like I said I did unit
code not even once but I did it and now
I'm NE deep in this stuff um so we got
bit functions right now we have bit
functions that describe like endian
things like endianness and zero leading
ones and all this other stuff in the
standard now and they're all part of the
standard right they're going to be
shipping with c23 you should be able to
access them they should give you direct
access to all these intrinsics and
everything else that have been on
compilers for I mean come on some of
these instructions are literally like
from the 80s literally Intel 8080 like
it that
why why did it take so long to get here
but anyway it's in it's in it's there
now it's there now I made sure it's in
there now so we're all good we have
endian stuff and we have bit operations
we have to get the rest of the bit stuff
in later right enumerations I fixed
those you can actually add a colon after
the name of the enumeration and then
specify a type right this is similar to
if you're seeed this like wow this is
old news but like if you're see this
like oh my God finally right because now
you have Dependable data types
underlying your numeration so you can
put them in structures you can generic
match on them and they have the expected
Behavior right
um all of that stuff so that just works
the way you expect it now we also have
checked integer stuff right mentioned
earlier in the panel and and Robert's
talk and in other places but now we have
standard way to opt out of undefined
behavior for integers right so if you
want to do a wrapping ad and you know
that's what you want to do then you use
the checked ad function or the check sub
function right to do subtraction or
check mole to do mole we didn't include
division because there's only one case
where division is UB and that's if
you're I believe it's if you're
dividing it's it's it's it's not the 0
by0 case it's like if dividing in Min by
something by minus one yeah and and
that's the I mean we should probably add
CKD div anyway just to cover that case
but you know it's it's simple
enough I mean we say trust the
programmer but like you know this is
also a security feature so maybe we
should just add check div right but you
know we didn't do that um and also
implementations didn't have check div
like GCC has built in that map to the
CKD ad and CKD sub stuff and like they
didn't have a div so we just didn't
include it right um there's a hand back
there
yes
microphone so you don't do check if I'm
assuming you also then don't do check
modul uh we because this has the exact
same overflow yeah we don't do check
modul yeah we don't we only have these
we only have checked ad checked sub and
checked uh mole um so again we probably
should add those but you know we it's
it's a top for another time um but you
know you can do this right you can do
City ad right so I'm uh imple I'm uh
initializing this 32t to zero we added
empty brace initialization that was an
extension that was implemented
everywhere so I was like it's very silly
that we don't put this in the standard
so I did put it in the standard so now
you can just use empty braces and that
means you can initialize everything with
it um and it will Zero the bits
including the padding bits which is
different from C++ in C++ the padding
bits will be whatever with C when you do
this with the empty brace you'll get
padding bits at equal zero right which
means it's also secure to use in your
kernel right just fun fact um so that
will work and you you can do you can use
the Boolean to check if it did wrap and
obviously you'll get a Boolean back that
says it did wrap and then the value is
zero right because you did one plus you
and Max and so it just rolls over one
and so you get zero right and so well-
defined Behavior no UB San won't trigger
all that stuff is good
right we also have proper keywords now
right so we got our hands dirty and we
said all right we're we're sick of this
whole you uncore boore capital S stuff
we're doing with these keywords like
let's just make them real keywords and
so we did so you don't have to clue to
header anymore you just get these
keywords and you get false and true and
all other stuff right there's some
mitigation techniques we had to do for
false and true to make sure that we
didn't break anybody right um and so
vendors can do you know uh hash toine
for their true and false to make sure
that you know your people who are
checking for if true or if false will
not be broken and stuff like that but uh
we did add some mitigations for that to
make sure that they're
okay and a ton more like this is
actually two pages of what's called nxm
in the standard that just lists a bunch
of changes we made a lot of the changes
we made right
um and we have to ask ourselves
like maybe the common denominator was
never existing practice right we kept
going harder and harder in like no
invention without no inventing stuff no
exceptions right always standardized
existing practice right but the things
we added solve material problems that
actually will help people
and in this case for a lot of these
cases this is stuff that like
implementers did do some of these things
but for most of the changes that gotten
see they came from people right Tom
McDonald
put vas in the standard because he had a
numerical Computing background he wanted
C to compete with Fortran and APL and
the other languages that he was using in
his lab right Hans Bim right for the
atomics and the memory model right he
did tons of work right he's still he's
still active in the committee he's still
doing work for atomics and and the
memory model right both C and C++ you
know people who fight against status quo
like Jen gustad he's the one who's
respons responsible for the keywords he
fixed up several language and Library
features fixed up atomics a bunch of
other stuff Aaron Balman who's not here
um but did a tributes to bit in right
which is a variably sized integer right
um not variably sized as in runtime but
like you can stick a constant expression
in the bit int and you can basically say
it's 63 uh bits wide or you can say it's
72 bits wide or you can say it's 24 bits
wide and you can actually choose how big
it is right so this stuff kind of
applies directly to fpgas where you want
to be able to PR precisely code how many
bits you're using right save you know on
on your fpj's resources right and then
of course we got things like consur and
V start with a list without having to
pass the first parameter so you can have
a dot dot dot function in C that doesn't
require our first parameter anymore
right so you can literally just have a a
plain dot do Dot and then just go
through the list as normal right without
any kind of like extra format parameter
or like number parameter whatever
telling you what to do um and all of
these came from people right they didn't
come from implementations we didn't try
to like standardizing practice it was
just somebody saw a need and fulfill
that need
right and that was the actual Spirit of
SE
right this is Dennis Richie I mean most
of you probably know who this is
right when they were starting to
standardize c89 before they started
writing charters before they started
getting you know they started trying to
codify everything right Dennis
Richie changed something about SE just
before it was standardized right in
particular in 198 9
right he made sure that bna's changes in
C++ because at this time B was actually
actively working on C++ and it was a
real
thing he actually
cribbed the function prototypes he
actually I wouldn't say crib or stole
because it was with consent obviously
but like he took the Syntax for actual
types with your arguments because you
didn't have that in C before c89 you
didn't have types you could associate
with arguments and so we actually took
that from C++ and put it in C and not
only did he put it in C but he
immediately deprecated the feature that
has his name on it K andr declarations
are named after kernigan and Richie but
this guy
knew that what he was going to be
standardizing what he was going to be
working with was more
important than the thing that had its
own name on
it right and so this is an interview
from 2000 but he also writes this down
in in his writings right about the fact
that they when they were standardized in
c89 they crib this feature right and
so we need to be able to embrace making
changes and we need to be able to brace
them the same way that Dennis did
right if Richie can see that something
is better and put it in his language and
deprecate his own beloved
feature if he can do that if he can look
at that that situation and make that
kind of technical call
then maybe it's not about how much we
standardize dising practice maybe it's
not about how much we're focusing on oh
does this come with a comp uh uh
commercial implementation of comp maybe
it's just if it's a good idea or
not and maybe we should start focusing
our Charter not on how many compilers
implement the thing but whether or not
it's a good idea and whether or not it
passes design
muster and if we do
I think that we will see
better hopefully sometime within our
life thanks